So that was the pre-conditions and as is
usually the case the pre-conditions
are easier than the post-conditions.
So we want to next look at the what
it means, assuming that we've past
the pre-conditions,
to actually check something out.
What affect is that going to
have on our information system.
Okay, so take a minute and think what
you expect to happen when the item is
checked out and list them in English.
>> So I think my mom was
the obvious post condition is
now the book's checked out.
So a way to say that or express that I
thought wouldn't go back to that item's
currently checked out operation that
belongs to the patron class and
say that the set that's returned from
that operation should contain this
new loanable item that's
been checked out.
>> So, this raises
an interesting [COUGH] issue.
So we're specifying an operation.
And we're specifying one operation
in terms of another operation.
Okay?.
And we can do that, that's fine.
However, the real change of state here
has to do, so
the items currently checked out.
Is a query operation
that reflects the state.
We could more directly say what's
the change in the state, okay?
So what other post
condition do you have?
>> So the other condition I have I
think is more related to this, I guess,
is that a checked out, we have that, a
class represented on our email diagram.
There has to be an instance
of that now for
this particular operation
that has just occurred.
>> Okay.
So
we have the association
class checked out.
>> Yes.
>> And
[COUGH] the effect of
checking out something new
would mean that there's another
link in that association class.
>> Yes.
>> Instance of that.
And, if there is another link there,
then, by implication,
the items currently checked
out will return that new item.
>> Correct.
>> So
we don't have to state both of those.
>> Okay.
>> We only have to say
that the association has one more thing
in it and we get the other one for free.
However, there's another post condition.
Recall the business about requests.
Okay, so
what would the post condition there be?
>> So, the request queue is now
one less than it was prior.
Someone has such it
popped off the queue,
because a checked out
operation has occurred.
>> Well, it had better be you,
because you're doing the checking out.
We can't just get rid
of an arbitrary person.
>> The implied patron
should be the one who's-
>> Right, okay.
So, we already have
a precondition which says that
this particular patron is
eligible because either
there's no request in which case
there's nothing to pop off.
Or if there is a request out there, the
first one on the list had better be you.
So in that latter contingency we do want
to pop off your name, okay from there.
So we're going to state the post
condition but it's going to be a little
tricky to state because it's only in
the case where you were on the list.
>> Right, and it sounds like
an implication because we just had like
another only if the case of
it's a child this happens.
So only if the case that you were
the patron on the checkout request list.
>> Bingo.
>> Okay, cool.